formidable
c'est formidable c'est une formidable
idée qu elle succède à helsinki de ces
formidables si vous êtes gentils à leur
domicile à nyons et un triangle un
triomphe et puis on peut dire que vous
avez tapé dans le mille 1 va pas vivre
900 à 1000 par dix lacs d et puis on va
j'ai vu un vous avez vos affiches sur
tous les murs de paris comme ça je
remercie mon rôle est alors qu'est ce
que vous devez être fiers quand même à
bien sûr que ça fait plaisir parce que
si je vous disais le contraire ma
chambre et hypocrite
vient alors je me rappelle l'unicef
changement avec les débuts je me
rappelle les débuts d'ee vous allez vous
passion numéro un dans un musical ce
travail là bas nous ici en levée de
corps sans je me rappelle même vous
arriviez au métro vous arrivions vous
vous preniez une vitre pour arrive au
théâtre puis même que ce n'était pas une
première
ouais c'est en deuxième et avait pas
troisième je me rappelle vous étiez mal
fagotée en beauté mal foutu
c'est normal si tu aimais début
c'étaient des vues ou immatures et
maintenant si la gloire
ouais c'est la gloire vous avez des
rhumatismes quoi mais ça c'est les
sports il a donc dû adopter aussi triste
vous soyez et je suis enfant j'ai fait
alors évitez mois et puis alors
maintenant je parle pas vous parler des
voyages des tournées forte et même à
l'étranger et ailleurs et puis on entend
on entend vos chansons à la radio
j'entends que j'entends à la radio eu
une saute sur un levier syrie de la
louve est remis à la valse à mille des
flamands la vie vous on peut dire que
vous vous en avez fait du chemin
monsieur monsieur monsieur on sait
maintenant déjà on est vraiment peu de
choses